oh
wow oh
i will look at the phone yes there yes
hello
editor you hear that lixie you're
demoted to editor again
[Laughter]
fortunately it's all sorted and properly
filed and it's up to you to figure out
what exactly happened after each
accident don't worry thanks to the brand
new software we've got your vr headset
it's much more fun than it sounds what
could be more fun than exploring uh
gruesome accidents
which is what this game is all about hi
everybody my name is markiplier welcome
to accident
today we are accident investigators
because who doesn't want
that simulator and that's what we have
today so
what we're going to do is we need to put
the cd of each case into your laptop run
the software that pops into your screen
and pull on the vr headset from then
you'll be controlling our heroes right
from the moment they arrive at the scene
i have no idea how it works that's
always a good sign by the way the first
scenario is a tutorial highly recommend
you start with that one
okay sure uh you hear that
accidents virtual
that was a baby it's a dummy it could be
a baby dummy i don't know
this cds cd baby scd
call the ambulance as soon as you can
the sooner they arrive the more chances
the victims have
oh they're not dead oh why am i on the
scene first
why am i the first responder shouldn't
they be the first responder
why am i probably the insurance cri
am i crashing am i dying oh god please
okay good yeah here officer markiplier
on the scene
call him oh yeah hello
one 911 what country is that
what country has emergency as 112.
okay thank you parent from peanuts call
um i thought i did that
why aren't you them can you give cpr on
this dummy can i do
turn on the hat right that's a good
point
that's a good point who am i
i feel like i'm some accident insurance
uh
manager and that's why i was tailing
these people and maybe costing accident
myself i don't know why am i looking
over here
put up put out the fire how do i get out
of the car
okay uh excuse me you'll be fine i'm
not a professional but i'm here to help
warning sign of the top right is
displayed if there's something in need
of your immediate action
like a fire i don't see no oh my god
there's a fire
good lord there's a fire okay um
sure good thing you had an accident in
this convenient hangar
okay skadoosh
sploosh flash flam
flambe it's not doing nothing it does
nothing it's not doing nothing
is it doing it there we go
damn this game is kind of cool not gonna
lie this game kind of well made i didn't
expect i was expecting like crap where
some
i just i have to what
when helping always follow these four
steps call for help secure the area
assess the sewage and help the victims
okay is it getting the area
i need to turn off this car i don't know
how you made it out there
there's or okay if i'm an investigator
there's clearly something already going
poorly
how did both victims who are
bleeding get removed from the car which
crashed into
apparently nothing and then ejected
both passengers out of the car oh
wow the driver's seat definitely shot
through so
this person must have been the driver
got shot out cut up on the glass
while this one was actually behind
the driver waiting lurking ready to
strike
with a garrote wire he ran his hands
through the driver's hair group wire
around the neck
strangled the driver causing the driver
to lose control
spin out hit that then spin out again
ejecting both passengers straight out
the front onto these conveniently placed
blankets it's the perfect crime
turn off hey boss i did it
the lower left you can see the hud icons
representing all the victims with their
respective health bars
oh yeah they're alive when a health bar
reaches zero that person dies and the
scenario fails this doesn't count if the
victim was dead before your arrival
to know which health bar belongs to
which victim you need to inspect them
excuse me while i cop a field to inspect
hmm
let's look at those lips nope never mind
gently shake the shoulder
you awake sir can you hear me
can you sir sir please can you hear me
sir
you all right you okay there oh it's
gone ah man
okay check for breathing let me just
gently shake your lips you're right
what oh my god why is this dummy
breathing that shouldn't be happening
that's a [ __ ] horror movie
right now oh
[ __ ] what's the opposite of asmr
i can't last i'm sorry i'm gonna look at
your wound
that's a wound all right yeah that's
also a wound
oh my god oh the chest is moving oh no
all right thanks bud i'll be right with
you let me check your murderer
you okay hey hey hey you okay there
yeah you're right why are we trying to
kill that man huh
admit it just admit it everything will
go easier if you just admit it to me
if you made a mistake you can rewind did
i did i dick around for too long
i might advice
no what have i done oh oh i see i
i didn't i let go too soon
okay so oh hi what
okay but i don't know if i made a
mistake did i made a mistake sir
you all right sir you okay i'm gonna
listen to you breathe again which is my
favorite thing
okay so they're alive and they have two
wounds okay you
sir sir and you're
dead got it
victims who aren't breathing should be a
top priority as long as you're able how
am i supposed to know
if they are just not breathing or
they're dead
because and i'm just saying this like
what if i'm just doing cpr on a dead guy
anyway here comes first aid my dude
let's get my gloves on get the mask
ready
nope apparently not open the airway
how do i do that
this is a bad time for me to hate
mannequins oh all right cpr mask
in hand right yeah chest compression
time baby
start going dunk slower
oh my god he's really goosh in there
you're gonna be
fine you're gonna see your mannequin
family again your mannequin children
your mannequin wife or husband whatever
faster slower perfect i'm the best
i'm the greatest there ever was oh hmm
what am i doing what am i doing what do
i do
what
wow one
okay two breaths and then compression
no breathing oh
no
what is happening what is any of that
what is that point am i supposed to kill
this man
am i finishing the job in this exercise
your job is to collect relevant evidence
and figure out what was the cause of the
accident i already figured it out
this person who tried to murder that
driver who got his just desserts
caused an accident and ended up dead
unfortunate it's unfortunate
okay muffler debris clue plays this
evidence
in first position two something
a thingamabob uh a bobbum a thing
debris a tire was it missing a tire
put the events in the correct order f
[Music]
what i'm sorry what
one two three
four
i did it this is just
dead i didn't even need to help the
other one oh they both died i'm
just an idiot well that was depressing
the most depressing way to learn how to
be a weirdo that finds auto accidents
all the time
why am i this
[Music]
well time to drink my sorrows away hey
now you finish the tutorial you can
start working on the real thing
amy what's happening what's happening
here
what's going on here amy has prepared
two cases for you to solve just remember
if you have any
problems you can always redo the
tutorial we've got mark
amy editor what is happening here
accidents so there's gotta be some real
stuff
that i can enjoy okay let's look at this
bastard sad you've run out of time
considering completing the tasks in a
different order
how much time do i have what i learned
from the test dummies is they're gonna
die no matter what i do
so why even bother right everybody why
even bother
well this is just beautiful why's this
game look so good my computer can't
handle it
oh that's a problem wait where did that
other truck come from how'd that other
truck get going going over there if this
whole road's blocked up
oh that's the criminal right there
that's that's the problem okay emergency
call it in hey hey we got problem here
hey hello
okay make sure the area is safe
the area is stunning okay um
is the area safe any fires
oh no oh my god this is gonna be legit
okay i could make jokes about dummies
but these are computer characters i'm
gonna really feel bad about this
okay where's my triangle um whole
50 meters okay cool sure that makes
sense
blap do i gotta put one on the other
side probably i don't have another
oh oh oh he got a problem
uh any of you guys got an emergency
triangle uh seem to be a needed one i
can't
jump so i don't know how i'm gonna get
to you guys do you have one
you have a triangle jammed well ain't
this just a kerfuffle
i object to this horrendous treatment of
me oh my god
oh my are you okay sir probably not turn
off the ignition in all vehicles
uh just gonna reach past you here there
we go
for now if ignition helps prevent
electrical systems from starting a fire
the more you know i don't have another
triangle
am i spot am i dumb am i an idiot
how does one do that oh
my i hate you i hate you i did i thought
this was just like monster oh
i didn't see the yellow bulbous sack on
the tree
nah i didn't see that that's my fault i
can see how that's my fault
so clearly now i need to mark another
location on the other side
where is it i don't see it where is it
do one of you have a triangle is that i
should try to rip that bad boy off that
sign
i'm gonna put it on the road give me a
triangle
you better have a triangle do you have a
triangle you got trout
well i would have loved to know that i
was supposed to do that but
i guess i had to figure it out one of
these people is gonna die and i'm gonna
fail
everything okay anybody on fire
no i can't even blast you for jokesies
all right um
turn off that i gotta go before these
people expire
um all right try find where you are
try your gps if you have one what do you
mean
woman look at the stars where's the moon
i don't know my car built-in gps is a
tesla
sat nav there i am okay when giving your
location try to avoid gps coordinates
since they can be imprecise use road
names and distances
okay check every victim to see who needs
your help the most i'll relay that to
the
paramedics okay cool hey
aristotle i know your name somehow
yup you okay
okay he breathing he breathing he
probably not doing too good
okay uh octavio pagnotto
hey ma'am ma'am ma'am you okay
unbuckle seatbelt oh
no i hate it oh i hate this oh my god i
hate that
i could never i mean i could i mean
clearly
oh my god jesus christ if she's dead i'm
gonna be so upset
okay you're not dead okay you're you're
alive
oh my god oh my god
no you're dead was a broken neck
oh oh my god
[Music]
oh the [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god holy [ __ ]
oh my god
okay i need to help you holy [ __ ] need
first aid oh am i gonna need the utility
knife probably
okay here we go buddy uh i wasted so
much time
but here we go cut off the branch
well this is inefficient or that's an
extremely sharp knife
put on gloves get the sibbers
and we're gonna take care of yous buddy
we're gonna take care of you don't worry
we got this
i got gauze in hand
there we go apply pressure till help
arrives
well this game is gonna be messed up huh
and i guess that should have been
obvious considering it's about
horrific car crashes and analyzing
thereof
jesus gather all the clues okay sure
yeah
skid marks aristo turns away from the
accident but loses control and hits a
tree
well well well pamphlet unsecured logs
falling off the logging
that's my nightmare ever since i saw
final destination 2
my nightmare has been logs falling off
of a truck and it's
horrifying when the log smashes into
this is
a branch clue a loose branch gets stuck
in the compact car's wheel making it
impossible to turn
horrible shouldn't you like go shouldn't
you go
okay so what happens is logs fall off
trailer
log hits that
can't turn and then finish off
done luckily for
eriosto the branch to pierce his chest
missed his lungs
this and your immediate help ensured
that despite a minor infection his wound
healed a short time
i sure took my time but he's alive and
that's what matters
oh the log killed polito on the spot
dude that was the truck the truck that
drove by me that was the criminal truck
no no
no oh my god nine at the time was raised
by his godfather and his family later in
his life became a paramedic
oh no oh no you're never confident
enough to drive a car
oh no oh this is not gonna be a fun game
jeremy christmas
fascinated so much work went into this
game i mean it's an educational
experience that's for sure
i don't think people would be playing
this for fun no way in hell
march 4th oh my god these are in the
future jesus christ
oh no we can prevent this we can save
these people
i think probably oh but this is good
information now i know what to do
if i ever come across a car accident
call emergency
hazards get out your triangles i gotta
get triangles man
lots of triangles like too many
triangles oh here i go
lenin i'm not gonna try oh blast we're
an oblast in the future oh
well that's a problem do a sweet
180 bro not all this safety stuff
aren't i a little far from oh oh
oh oh ah ah
i don't know the number right here no
salsa oh that's a problem
what do i do uh how do i do i gotta run
and get
oh my god oh what happened oh my god
horrible oh excuse me
harder than me oh my god
oh my god how about here no bars ah damn
it
so do i just gotta go around till i get
bars if somewhere here it's got to be
reception i just gotta run around like a
like an idiot until i find it oh is
there like a pay phone
is there a payphone hey phone hey phone
over there
oh my god i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
i'm gonna die pay phone phone of pay
pay my phone this is a very strange
building but okay
do you have a phone you got a phone in
there
your phone hello hello
your phone work you got phone at work
phone work hello ah you have
bar i see oh one one two again
so that must be here
okay so i gotta turn off these oh my god
oh god hey let me squeeze in here buddy
boo
um all right see ya
later dude please be careful in crossing
the street
yeah i i've figured that out okay let me
get my triangle
no let me get my triangle where do i put
it
where do i put in the middle in the
middle of the road in the middle
in the mid where do i put it i don't
know where to put it oh i see oh okay
all right yeah that's gonna help
don't kill me
oh thread the needle
i'm fine hey there's a problem are you
gonna slow down
not even a little bit try to move the
planks
well okay i'm glad you assume that i am
incredibly strong
which i am but also you could
not yeah whatever i'll do it okay move
this move that move that excuse me
pardon me excuse me pardon me excuse me
pardon me
uh hello hi i'm gonna turn that off
thank you
okay let's see what you got here hey
buddy buddy igor
yeah right there none of these people
are gonna be able to hear me
i have a funny feeling unbuckle open
here we go open wide
definitely breathing oh this one don't
look so good uh
blocked by a window maybe if i roll the
window down with these amazing power
windows
uh-huh amazing incredible uh hello
let me slide in here ma'am
ma'am open or open up
oh i hate this
thing i mean i know it's probably how
it's done but also
you know okay so i don't know if my gps
is going to work but might as well try
it
i'll have to hop into the other one and
see how that goes
uh
[Music]
okay i gotta go try the other but i'm
gonna bring a
a medical kit i'm coming buddy
hold on you won't be able to no i'm
coming till i shake your
shoulder hello sir sir
sir sir
hello whoa that's a big wound
but you're breathing
okay i think i need to help this one and
maybe the old lady too
they're all stable are they stable
protect the victims from the cold
how do i do that how i don't have
blankets what do you mean
what do you mean protect a bit oh pull
them out right do i have to cross the
road with this guy
oh [ __ ]
yeah protect them from the cold by
putting them in the snow
yeah pick them up
who picks people up like this all right
buddy oh my god
oh we're gonna play the worst game of
frogger ever oh no this is awful oh this
is terrible
oh this is horrible what
where do i put him oh my god
i'm aware i'm aware thank you i don't
know where to put him he's very cold
and this is a very inefficient way to
carry someone oh in my car
oh okay in my car that makes a lot of
sense this guy's gonna die
i'm too slow my car is in my car
i bet my car so don't try to efficiently
pack him in there just
right in the back buddy hey lady you
wait your turn lady
we're go oh uh roll that window up
you seem a little uh nippy
close i guess
who's the fourth victim says three or
four so why is it three and four
close
what is that wes i don't know what the
name i don't know what i'm doing
okay all right i i know what i'm doing
now all right you're coming with me
vlad we're gonna put some stuff on your
head and we're gonna carry you across
this really really untrustworthy road
all right come with me all right here we
go okay
it's fine it's fine okay what happens if
you get hit
oh that's what happens so don't
do that all right i'm out okay vlad
we're going globba's
bandage bam done pick up like a
boost not gonna get hit by a car
not gonna get hit and then we just pop
him in my car
close up the other car which for some
reason worked i don't know
maybe i guess i could have just closed
the door but
i guess maybe not how about in the
really passenger doors locked really
those doors are locked fun okay all
right i see how it is
okay close that close that close that
and then i'm actually gonna close all
this and they'll apparently be fine
perfectly stable roll that up in fact i
did most of the problem by opening
everything up
all right wait for help to arrive how i
just wait
in here
oh okay cool or at least no one's dead
this time
hello everyone's dead
well now i have to investigate don't i
discover the cause all right good
clues okay cool well seems like they
wreaked havoc because they don't like
slams break was locks for all four
wheels the idiot
what are you even doing
crashes his car into the park shed okay
but why was it an intent to murder
didn't love his wife anymore wanted to
cause a calamitous accident
i see how it is has this finally been
blocked off am i in trouble okay i think
i think it's good so there's gotta be oh
vladimir loses control of his car while
changing lanes
interesting fascinating ooh what is this
and just control the slide and turn into
a parking area oh
la vadim collides with mishkin's car i
thought it was vlad i'm an idiot pickup
spins around and slides into a tree
you're right about that okay so using my
biggest brain possible vladim
vadim loses control vadim collides
pickup spins around slides into a tree
manages to control the slide
turned into a parking area slams breaks
hits the thing
done scenario success
for me despite losing consciousness
after hitting the shack igor didn't
suffer any serious injuries
paramedics were able to revive him on
the way to the hospital and he was able
to leave the next day well okay
that's good during the accident minor
injuries advanced age
her recovery was slow and problematic
with the support of her husband and
children she left the hospital after a
few months a few months
months good god head injury wasn't the
most serious threat to his life
colliding with the tree crushed several
of his ribs
which caused a lot of internal damage
including a punctured lung
long recovery time that he had to close
his business well that's sad
oh okay redeem unless it's logging and
you happen to cause another mountain
accident somewhere
this is fascinating okay i think i'm
good for now because
otherwise i think this this game is
going to send me into a spiraling
depression but
fascinating right fascinating that this
is a game and it's
very well made like this is extremely
well made
i'm gonna leave this here but if you
guys want to investigate accidents which
is a fascinating thing to say that you
can do i mean
check it out what else can i say about
it it was not an experience that i was
prepared for but
you know i'm not upset that it exists i
mean this is cool i learned a lot which
actually is strange when it comes to
gaming
but thank you for watching and learning
with me
and now you know and armed with your
knowledge we can save lives
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye